welcome to this comprehensive video
course on testing JavaScript
applications using Cypress you'll dive
deep into the world of end in testing as
you learn about setting up writing and
executing robust tests to ensure the
reliability and performance of your web
applications Ryan Solomon teaches this
course he has been using Cyprus
professionally for many years and he's a
great instructor
let's get started today you're going to
learn everything you need to know
regarding testing your JavaScript
application using Cyprus and not only
that but you're going to be able to see
my dog ragdar in the background quite a
bit as well so with that we are going to
cover every single little thing and bore
you with every little detail of Cyprus
I'm going to cover the fundamentals to
get you up and running that will allow
you to use Cypress to test your
professional applications in JavaScript
I've been using Cypress the last three
or four years in my professional job so
I think that this is going to help you
on a ton and I'm going to go over the
fundamentals of what you need to know
and some best practices so you can use
it well for your job now the only
prerequisite for this course is basic
web development knowledge so JavaScript
CSS and HTML if you have the
fundamentals down for those you can take
this course now with that we are going
to be writing Cypress tests in this
course for a next.js application now
nextgis is not a prerequisite for this
course as everything I go over it's more
so just going to be JavaScript specific
not next.js specific so whether you want
to test a just vanilla Javascript app or
an angular or view or spelled or
whatever it might be this will apply to
everything because we're going to focus
on the fundamentals and principles of
Cyprus so you can apply those principles
to whatever JavaScript application you
decide to test here okay now let's kind
of dive into the course a little bit and
what we're going to kind of cover here
so I've created a custom xjs application
here or website for this course in which
you can visit that I'm sure that will be
linked in the description here below but
you can visit that at https colon
forward slash forward slash Cypress
hyphen
course.versell.app okay and once you
visit this website you're going to see
that this is basically an outline of the
course but we're also going to use this
website to write our Cypress test we're
going to write tests for this website so
for this we're going to cover why Cyprus
so different reasons on why Cyprus is a
good idea here we're going to just do an
overview and an install of our app so
I'm gonna have you clone a repo of mine
and then we're going to install
dependencies and move forward with that
then we're going to focus on some
testing fundamentals of Cyprus and we're
going to get into what our described
blogs it blogs commands interacting with
things different things like that then
we're going to cover some stuff that is
good to know regarding forms and we have
this input here that we are going to
actually write tests for and a little
subscribe Button as well and then we're
going to get into some other
just general examples that I've kind of
found helpful and some use cases that I
think will be good for you to know about
so multi-page testing using intercepts
and other kind of helpful Cypress
methods that I think are helpful to know
and then we're going to get into
component testing so Cyprus is a
end-to-end testing framework so it
focuses on just end-to-end workflows for
your user not necessarily writing tests
in isolation for specific JavaScript
component that you have but sometimes
you don't necessarily want to write
tasks for complete end-to-end you want
to test a specific component and for
that Cyprus provides a really good way
to do that as well so we'll cover
component testing as well and then we're
going to end with some different best
practices here so eight different best
practices that I think will help make
your Cypress test a lot better and help
you have a much easier time with that so
with that I think that we are ready to
kind of head into the first segment here
of why Cyprus so
why might you actually want to use
Cypress for your testing of JavaScript
applications well the first reason is
because Cypress is an all-in-one testing
framework it has an assertion Library as
well as it provides ways of doing
different mocks and stubs for different
functions and stuff like that so gone
are the days of when you attest a
JavaScript application you'd have to ins
install like seven different libraries
one that does the kind of testing
framework itself one that is a specific
assertion Library one that does mocking
and stubbing Cyprus does all of that for
you so you basically and you'll see in
our install here you basically just
install Cyprus and everything else is
already taken care of for you so you
don't have to install a bunch of
different libraries and packages for it
reason number two I like Cyprus is
because it focuses on kind of end-to-end
and component testing in more of a real
world environment so you can actually
like write end-to-end test testing your
entire application in different
workflows that the user is actually
going to be going through rather than
just wording unit tests and isolation
then you know sometimes you write tests
and it's not even a particular situation
that the user will go through you're
more so writing tests to make sure that
your tests are working so Cyprus does a
really good job of focusing on things
that the user is actually going to be
interacting with and different things
like that to where I think it's much
more real world than potentially some
other Solutions out there and then also
it runs in the browser and it's Row in
JavaScript so since it's wrote in
JavaScript it's great for testing
JavaScript applications you don't have
to go and learn a completely different
language or different syntax or writing
these tests it's basically just writing
them in JavaScript and you'll if you
know JavaScript you'll pick this up very
quickly and it also runs in the browser
which has some benefits which will show
you here just in a little bit and also
generally has pretty good performance
and it can be integrated into a
continuous integration or continuous
development environment quite easily we
recently did this for our professional
app to where we run our Cypress tests
after we merge a pull request to our
kind of main branch as well so that can
be integrated and you can get code
coverage and all that stuff as well so
you can be notified right away if your
code coverage goes down after a certain
PR or you can know right away when you
merge PR if certain tests start failing
it is very helpful to do so it's good
with that sort of thing we also have
native access to the Dom and tier app so
you can inspect your Cypress test like
debug them similar to how you would
debug a regular JavaScript application
and then also within the Cyprus test
Runner you have access to your
application which means that when you're
writing tests once a test stops you can
within the Cypress Runner just go use
your application and go and find things
that is super helpful so you don't have
to keep going back and forth between
your test Runner and your actual app to
kind of know what you're testing you
have access to it in the test run or
which if that doesn't make sense it'll
make sense here in just a little bit and
then also there's I personally think
there's a great developer experience for
Cyprus I have used it like I said for a
few years now and I really enjoy using
it I think that for testing libraries
like if you're willing to use it for a
handful of years it must be pretty solid
so that's good and then also it's
generally not flaky if you fold the best
practices there's definitely ways that
you could write Cypress test that does
make them flaky but if you follow the
best practices you can generally have
non-flaky test what I mean by flaky is
that you have tests that you don't you
run your your testing Suite once over
your test passed you run it again a few
of them fail you run it again they all
pass so they just have tests that don't
always pass and they're just kind of
flaky they sometimes as sometimes don't
I don't tend to run into that when using
some of the best practices that Cyprus
recommends here okay so now with that
kind of overview on why you might want
to use Cyprus let's kind of get into
actually getting you set up with this
project so we can start actually testing
with Cyprus so the very first thing that
we're going to do here is we're going to
clone this repository so I'm going to
copy this command here git clone and
then the name of my repository and I'm
sure that will have my GitHub where you
can find this linked below
I will have kind of this this starter
repository here in which we are going to
write our tests and then I will also
include a kind of final project that has
all my tests written so you can kind of
see the before and after so you can see
the Cypress course and then I'll have
like Cypress course final that you can
see the kind of final things there and
I'll have those linked below but I'm
going to copy this here so git clone
https colon forward slash github.com
coderion Solomon forward slash
cypresscourse dot get and then I'm going
to go into vs code here
and within Visual Studio code I'm going
to open up my terminal and I'm in a
folder called acyclone final you can
name this folder whatever you want but
just be in a certain folder that you
want this project to be in and then I'm
going to paste that command of git clone
and then it's got clone into my
repository and now that I have cloned my
repository if I look at my folders I see
I have my Cypress course so I'm going to
CD into
my Cypress
course here and then now once I'm in my
Cypress course we're going to go back
here and we're going to install the
dependency so npm install so I'm going
to run that within my Cypress course
folder and that's going to install some
different dependencies that I used for
this project I use like material UI a
little bit to just write some different
components and stuff like that so we can
see that I'm now in my Cypress course
I've installed my dependencies so if I
go to my project Navigator over here and
I open up Cypress course you're gonna
see
that it's an xjs application so I use
the latest version of nexjs that uses
the app router so I have my app right
here and then I have my different
folders in next.js each folder
represents a route if you have a page.js
within that folder well we don't need to
get into nickjess here you could check
out coderide on YouTube to check out my
channel in which I cover next.js a bit
more but here you can see that we have
our best practices page we have some
various components we have our component
testing page examples fundamentals stuff
like that we're not going to get into
the kind of project itself a whole bunch
and we're going to focus on Cyprus but
if you want to learn more about nexjs as
I said you can go check out my channel
there but
with that we have our dependencies
installed here but now let's actually
run our application so let's do npm run
Dev here
in the terminal so that should start my
app here at localhost 3000 so if I go
back here you're actually going to see
that when navigating to localhost 3000
you see that this is indeed the website
I was just showing you so this is my
deployed website and this is at my
localhost 3000 here so this is the app
that we're going to test and it's also
the app that I use as in outline for
this course here okay so that should
start it up right here so with that
let's I'm gonna go back to the overview
page here within Locos 3000 now that
we've run our app let's now install
Cyprus so I'm gonna do npm install
Cyprus dash dash save Dash Dev
so I'm going to copy this here
and then I'm gonna go back I'm going to
open up another terminal here because my
other one's running and then I'm going
to make sure that since I'm still in my
Cyclone final I'm gonna still CD into
Cyprus
course here and then I'm going to run my
npm install Cyprus command
so I've now installed Cypress here after
just a second and now that I have Cyprus
installed and as you can see we just had
to install one package to get Cypress
all installed here in the configuration
of Cypress is actually quite easy as
well so let's go back here
and now the final step is to open the
Cypress test Runner and configure Cyprus
so I'm going to run MPX Cypress open
here
in my terminal and this is effectively
going to open Cyprus up in a test Runner
and as you see here you get a pop-up
window that says welcome to Cyprus and
right now we're going to focus on
end-to-end testing but in the future
we're going to go to component testing
here so I want you to click on in Twin
testing
and then once you do you're gonna see
that Cyprus is automatically going to
configure your Cypress project here so
it's automatically going to add these
different files to your Cypress project
so it's going to add a Cypress config.js
a Cypress support forward slash n2n.js a
cybersport commands so creating custom
commands in Cypress which will
definitely touch on in this course and
then you also have a Cypress fixtures
folder which will cover kind of what you
could use fixtures for here later on as
well so with that all you need to do to
configure Cypress is press continue
and bada bing it already does it I don't
know why I just said about a big I think
that's like a phrase from I don't know
the 90s I was barely alive in the 90s
but we're gonna start this in Chrome
here and as you can see it opens up this
Cypress test Runner here and what it's
saying is like hey you don't have any
any spec files another name for any test
file so you don't have any tests right
now so what you can do here is we can
create a new spec so here I want you to
click on create new spec and then once
we click on that it's going to add a
spec file or a test file within our
Cypress forward slash end-to-end forward
slash spec.sci.js
and what we're going to do here is
I'm going to call this fundamentals dot
psi.js as we're soon going to move on to
the fundamentals page and start actually
writing some tests and talking about
Cypress fundamentals so I'm going to
name this fundamentals right here I'm
going to click create spec
and then I'm going to press OK run the
spec
and here it created just a example test
for us and now we can set this test up
on our website and actually get into the
fundamentals of Cyprus but before we get
to the fundamentals just to show you
what happened here within our project
Cyprus automatically added some folders
into our project so within my project
here right next to my app directory
Cyprus added this folder called Cyprus
and within this Cypress folder it added
a few more folders so we have an
end-to-end folder and that's where our
fundamentals dot side.js folder is so
this is the spec file that we just
created using Cyprus when we clicked
create file and we named this
fundamentals it went into our Cypress
end-to-end fundamentals folder just to
be clear I did not just go and make all
these folders Cypress did all this
automatically for us when we clicked to
configure these files and then it also
adds a fixtures folder in which it gives
us just an example fixture and we can
get into this a bit later and then it
also gave us a support folder where we
can write our custom commands here and
do some other kind of configuration
things as well now not only this but it
also adds a
cypress.config.js folder to our root of
our application that we can also use to
kind of set up different configuration
things that we will also do here later
on okay so Cyprus automatically added
all this stuff for us we didn't have to
add a single thing we can already now
that we use that Cypress configurator we
can already dive into our Cypress folder
and our end to end test and get into
this fundamentals test and start writing
tests we didn't have to add any other
configuration other than that so Cyprus
as you could see it's super easy to get
set up in your projects you just install
the package you open it up run the
configuration it does it for you
automatically and you can start writing
your test so next up we're going to get
into the fundamentals of Cyprus this
might look a little bit forward to you
you have a describe block an itblock a
psi.visit how is all this working we're
going to Now cover that here in the
fundamentals section so here on the
fundamentals page of Cyprus the very
first thing that we're going to cover
here is
the describe blocks in Cyprus in which
all of your tests or your tests within
test file they're going to exist in a
describe block and this describe block
takes two arguments the first is just
going to be a string that is describing
your test file and the second is going
to be a callback function in which
you're going to actually have your tests
okay so if we go back to my code editor
here
what you're going to see is that within
fundamentals.sci.js we have this overall
describe block right here in which the
first argument to this describe block is
a string so instead of just naming this
template spec I'm going to name this
fundamentals
test
okay and then the second argument to
this describe block is a function a
callback function so passing a function
into another function in JavaScript
called the Callback function so I'm
passing a function as a second argument
and within the body of this second
argument here or this function that I
pass in as a second argument this is
going to contain all of my tests
and within this body of this function
here you see that I now have an IT block
so this is very similar
in which it's fundamental number two
within your describe block you'll also
have it blocks it blocks will be single
tasks within an overall test file the
API for it or the way that you use a it
block is very similar to a describe
block the first argument is the title of
an individual test and the second
argument is a callback function
containing your test code
so
your overall test or your your test file
is described by here describe blog and
then as a second argument to your
describe block you pass a function and
within the body of that function it's
going to contain your individual tests
for your overall describe block file
here so my describe block is my
fundamentals test I'm going to test my
fundamentals page and then my it block
that's going to be for individual tests
for my fundamentals page so here you can
see I have it and then I'm calling my it
function here
from Cyprus and then I'm passing in a
string is my first argument just like I
do for my describe block here and then
my second argument is going to be a
callback function or a function to which
the body of that function is going to
contain my test code here and you can
see this is a Cypress command that I'm
using right here which we'll get to in
just a second all right so
within the test file you're going to
wrap all of your tests in the describe
block describing what this test file is
going to test and then within that
describe block you are then going to
create it blocks that are going to be
your individual tests for that overall
file
all right
now I alluded to it just a second ago
but we also have commands and
interacting with elements so Cyprus
gives you various commands to help you
write your tests and you can use these
commands on the PSI object so Cyprus
makes a PSI object available to you that
is kind of globally available within
your Cypress test that you can use and
it gives you different Oprah methods on
that object that you can use to perform
different actions or to ask some
different things and stuff like that so
for example you can use the psi.visit
command so you're accessing the PSI
object that Cyprus gives you just
globally available you don't need to
import it at all and then you can access
the visit method on that object and that
can help you perform navigation
throughout your project so sci.visit
forward slash
is going to visit the kind of root of
whatever you set as your base URL and we
will cover setting a base URL here in
just a second as well but side out visit
forward slash like I said it will
navigate to your home page or your URL
for whatever is your base URL and then
you have various other commands like
side.click side.type side.check so on
and so forth and
if we look at their docs here in their
actionability section you can see that
they give various commands like click
double click right click type clear
check uncheck select trigger basically
any commands that a user can perform on
their keyboard or with their Mouse
Cyprus is going to give you that on the
PSI object so if we look at my code here
you can see that within my it block this
is going to contain my test code and I
do side at visit https colon forward
slash forward slash
example.cypers.io and what this is going
to do is it's going to navigate my test
to this URL here so that's why we see
that my test Runner right now is
pointing to example.cypers.io
but we don't want to test example that
cypress.io we want to test our actual
web page here so the way that we can do
this is instead of doing side.visit this
example.io
we can actually make sure to visit
localhost colon 3000 forward slash
fundamentals so if I copy
our URL for our running app and note you
must have your Dev server running for
Cyprus to work here if well I'll just
show you I'll shut down my Dev server so
hold on let me go back and now I'm going
to do side out visit
instead of this URL I'm gonna have a
visit localhost colon 3000 forward slash
fundamentals and now if I go back to my
Runner you see that it now lands on my
fundamentals page here
however
if I
go back to
my Dev server here and I shut it down
and I kill my server and then I try to
go back here and I refresh I'm gonna get
sorry we could not load localhost a
thousand forward slash fundamentals so
you need to have your Dev server running
for cyber star to work here
because you do get access to your live
running app here I think that this
should now work
when I reload it and now my page is up
and running again okay so just be aware
of that and one thing to keep in mind
when using
these different Cypress commands here is
that Cyprus does have an asynchronous
nature so what I mean by that is I'm
heading to the Cyber stocks here it
mentions that this is one of the most
crucial Concepts to understand when when
using Cyprus as Cyprus you know things
kind of asynchronously so Cyprus
commands do not return their subjects
this means you cannot do things like
using and we'll talk about getting
elements here in just a second but if
you do something like side out get
button and you would try to sign that
value to a button variable that will not
work and it mentions this is one of the
primary reasons they don't recommend
using variables within your test instead
Cyprus commands and yield their subjects
so Cyprus commands are asynchronous and
get queued for execution at a later time
while commands are executed their
subjects are yielded from one command to
the next similar to how like a
JavaScript generator function report
you'll want more information on
generator fugit stats that I'm going to
cover here it's a little bit more kind
of complex bar but I definitely have a
video on that on my channel but this is
because a lot of helpful Cypress code
runs between each command to ensure
everything is in order so instead of
doing something like this you can
actually use dot thens similar to how
you would do like promise chaining so it
says soul for command does not return
the subject but instead yields it how
can you interact with the subject
directly well you can use a DOT then and
Dot then behaves you know very similar
to Lee like I said how promises work in
JavaScript however dot then is a Cypress
command not a promise this means you
cannot use things like async await
within your cyber tests whatever is
returned from a callback function
becomes the new subject and will flow
into the following command so if you do
do something like hitting a button and
you want to use that button within your
tests then you would call a DOT then and
you'd be past the kind of HTML button
element and then you can make an
assertion within your dot then block
okay because Cyprus is asynchronous what
it's doing is different commands and
then it says when undefined is returned
by the Callback function the subject
will not be modified and will instead
carry over into the next command just
like promises you can return any
compatible Venable so anything that has
a DOT then interface and Cyprus will
wait for that to resolve before
continuing forward in your chain of
commands similar to how promises work
now you can also use dot rap so in the
example above the button is a jQuery
object this means that if we would like
Cypress to form some action on it we
first need to use side out rap or
Cypress to interact with it so for
example they would have to use side out
wrap around that button object and then
they could click on it and then they
could make a certain assertion so they
say in this example they're first
getting the button element but then they
are wrapping it with psi.rap because
they need to make it into a
Cypress object rather than just a button
element that's returned from the Dom
here so like it says here they need to
wrap it because it provides necessary
Cypress context to make these different
assertions on it okay so if you do use a
DOT then and then you want to make an
assertion on that element specifically
you need to wrap that first in side out
wrap okay most of the time you don't
need to use a DOT then and then make an
assertion on that button and we will
cover how to make assertions and we'll
go through examples in the future but
most of the time you don't need to do
this every once in a while though you do
so it's helpful to know that Cyprus is
asynchronous and you shouldn't just use
a variable like it shows here at the top
and if you want access to a native like
element on the Dom you should use a DOT
then and then if you want to make a
Cyprus assertion you should wrap that
element in a psi.rap okay so a little
bit of a trickier part here
but I would say just know that this is a
thing that you need to do if you need
direct access to an element usually you
don't and you can kind of get away with
not doing this but if you do need it
just know that this is how it should be
done rather than just assigning it to a
variable and moving forward thinking
that everything is just synchronous in
Cyprus okay
so hopefully that's clear
but moving back here let's now move to
getting elements so I kind of touched on
this just a little bit in that example
but like I mentioned here you're often
going to want to get an element from the
Dom and make some sort of assertion for
example my h1l link contains a certain
text so I might want to assert that this
title here says to testing the
fundamentals
and you can get almonds and Cypress by
using the git function and pass a CSS
query selector
okay now I will show you an example of
this here in just a second but the way
that you query for elements in Cyprus is
using psi.get and then as an argument
that you pass into side I get it's going
to be a string that is a CSS query
selector to get whatever element that
you want so knowing CSS is definitely
helpful for using Cypress which is why I
mentioned at the kind of intro that it's
helpful to know some just basic web
development when using Cyprus like CSS
HTML and JavaScript because you're going
to be querying for HTML elements and
kind of interacting with them as well
and then command chaining and assertions
so after you get an element you probably
want to do something with that element
like make an assertion so you can do
this by chaining on an assertion after
getting an element for example you might
get your H1 element with side I get and
then as soon as you get that element you
might call Dot contains text
and Cyprus has various ways of making an
assertion so if we look at their
assertions here you can see that Cypress
bundles the chai assertion library is
wool as the sidon and jQuery bringing
you a ton of very powerful assertions
right out of the box you don't need to
go and install chai and sign on and all
these different libraries you can use
them Cypress does this for you Autumn
automatically so for example and you
definitely don't need to memorize every
single Cyprus assertion I definitely
don't I you I've been using Cyprus in my
professional application for the last
three or four years and I I don't know
if I remember idiot surgeons off the top
of my head like psydoc contains a
certain text this is basically what I
remember but I will often just use chat
GPT and be like hey how do I make a
Cypress assertion to say that this
element does not exist in my dom and
judge you will just write that as search
or you could go the old-fashioned route
and just look at their dots and find out
um and sometimes as useful because BT
currently recording this in July 2023 it
only goes back to
I think 2021 so anything the last couple
years it might not know so it still can
be helpful to look at the docs as well
but just know that you can come to the
docks and look at their assertions and
you can see all these different
assertions they have so you can chain on
like after you get annulment you can say
it that should not equal a certain value
you can say all the keys should have a
certain name and value you can say that
something should exist you could say
that something should be undefined or
should be dot null you could say that
something has different arguments so you
can see there's a ton of different
assertions here pretty much any
assertion that you can think of it's
going to be included in these different
assertions here okay so you can come and
look through all these assertions if you
would like but as you can see we have a
ton so even for functions you should you
can do stuff like that should have been
cold you can have been called once have
been called twice have been called with
certain values a whole bunch of
different assertions in here okay so if
you want to learn all about Cypress
assertions you can come here but just
know that they have a ton
and if there's something that you
particularly want to do you can come to
this page and find that assertion for
the most part
but you can add new assertions by
extending the chai assertions and it's
kind of documented here within their
docs I'm not going to get into that too
much because Cyprus already has so many
assertions but just know you can add
your own assertions if there's something
that isn't available to you and here's
some examples of some common assertions
and Cyprus so you might use side at git
to get a list item that has a class
called selected so just like I mentioned
earlier and we'll we'll head into our
code editor and write this code in just
a second but here it's using the PSI
object it's calling digit to get an
element and then as an argument to side
I get you are going to pass it a string
that is a query selector to get an
element from the Dom so this query
selector is going to get all Li's that
have a DOT selected class and it's
asserting that there should be three
allies with a selected class so after
you get that element you chain on that
should have length of three
okay so this is saying your allies you
should have three selected allies on
your page
so
kind of going back to what I said
earlier about you not usually having to
assign something to a variable and then
using a DOT then because you can just
chain on that should have length of
three I don't need to say that then and
then get my elements and then assert
that these elements have a length of
three
I can just chain on my assertions here
and then similar to here it's getting a
form so side I get form and then it's
going to find the input within that form
and then it's going to say that should
not have class of disable
so it's saying the input in my form
should not have a class of disabled so
this is a good example of the chaining
nature of Cyprus similar to promise
chaining you're first going to get the
form and then you're immediately going
to chain on the dot find input to get
the input of that form and then you're
going to cheat on your assertion that
should not have class of disabled here
okay
and then also you can make different
assertions for Value so it's getting
this text area element and then saying
that should add value a fubarb as
and then here below this is getting text
content so it's getting an element that
has a data hyphen test ID which we will
get to test IDs in just a second it's a
test ID of username and then it's saying
it should have a certain text of Joe
Smith and it is a very similar thing for
D6 equals below and then to test a
visibility you can use side I get to get
a certain element and then you can say
that should be visible so you should be
able to see this on your page at this
point of time during your testing suite
and you can also do should not be
visible
now sometimes you don't want to test a
visibility you want to test existence
and the way that you can do that is
should not exist and then you can also
test during certain states of annulment
so this is getting radio buttons here
and it's saying that they shouldn't be
checked within your Dom and then you can
also test different CSS property so it
should have class of text decoration as
well as line through and then for this
element here it's saying it should not
have certain CSS and then you can also
test that certain properties are enabled
or disabled by using should be enabled
or should not DOT be enabled and then
you can also use negative assertions so
this is a positive assertion here so it
should have like two and it should have
a class of completed but this one is
saying it should not DOT have class of
completed and it should not DOT be
visible here all right so there are a
ton of different assertions that you can
use here hopefully this gives you kind
of a rough overview of how you can use
assertions and how the chaining works
but I think it'll make much more sense
once we kind of write the code for this
which I think that we are ready to do so
let's let's go back here
and
we covered describe blocks it blocked
command chaining getting elements and
some of the fundamentals that we need to
start writing kind of our first test
here so let's go ahead and all we're
going to do here is make an assertion
that this element right here contains
the text content of testing fundamentals
so my favorite way to do this is that
since Cyprus gives us access to our app
here I can automatically
inspect right here just like I'm
expecting the Dom and I can say okay how
should I worry for this element so it's
an H1 here
it has the content of testing
fundamentals but
I I don't really have a great way of
getting this element because in Cyprus
you don't want to use like super General
selectors as that can make your test a
little bit flaky and Cyprus recommends
using a data hyphen test attribute or
your element as
they don't want you to write your tests
in a flaky manner meaning you don't want
to write tests that like rely on like a
CSS class that can change a lot because
you don't want your test to fail just
because a certain class is changed you
want your test to fail when you get an
unexpected Behavior or an element isn't
showing that should be showing but just
because you necessarily
selected an element or queried for an
element and the class name convention
slightly changed you don't necessarily
want the test to break so they recommend
using selectors when you're getting
elements that are going to be constant
and not change a clause across your test
and not change much over time so they
recommend using data hyphen test
attributes so let's go ahead
and for this testing fundamentals H1
here let's add a data test attribute and
then we can write a test for this so
let's go back here
and I'm going to go over to my app
folder here
and I'm going to go to my fundamentals
folder and we're going to click on
page.jsx and you don't need to know
next.js to do this as you can see this
looks exactly like HTML this is
technically jsx but
for now we could just think of it just
like HTML and all I'm going to do is add
a data hyphen test attribute and I'm
going to set that to a string
cold fundamentals hyphen header here
and I'm gonna now copy this
actually I'm going to copy
this whole attribute right here and then
I'm going to go back to my
fundamentals.side.js
and I'm first going to visit HTTP colon
forward slash forward slash locals colon
3000 forward slash fundamentals but I'm
gonna actually change this in just a
second here
but I'm gonna go ahead and do
PSI dot get
and then as my argument here it's going
to be a query selector so I want to get
my data hyphen test attribute so to get
a attribute using query selector I need
to use my square bracket syntax I'm
going to paste in my data hyphen test is
equal to my fundamentals hyphen header
and for my test
well what do I want to test
I want to test that it contains the text
that I expect
so I'm going to do dot contains so I'm
chaining on my assertion here so I'm
saying site I get this element with a
data hyphen test attribute a
fundamentals header
and then I'm going to say it contains
and what's the text here that it should
contain testing fundamentals is the text
that it should contain so if I go back
here I'm going to paste that within my
side out contains but it should be a
string
well actually you can also pass a
regular expression into psydot contains
so I'm actually going to pass in forward
slash
testing fundamentals
forward slash and then I'm gonna pass an
I so this is making it case insensitive
and I often think that this can be
helpful because
often you don't really care if like if I
came back and I tested this or changed
this to testing and then lowercase f
fundamentals because that was more
consistent with my app or something like
that I didn't want it to be case
sensitive then I'll pass a regular
expression and pass an I here to be case
insensitive So within your contains I
could pass a string that would be just
fine but you can also pass a regular
expression so I'm getting my
fundamentals header and then I'm saying
it contains testing fundamentals so if I
go back to this you see that my test
does indeed pass now I could also do
something like this
in which instead of just saying that
contains testing polynomials I should I
could say that should
and then within my should assertion I
could say
contain text
and then I could pass a string testing
fundamentals and I believe that should
also still pass here and it does it
contains the task text testing
fundamentals
okay so hopefully you have written your
first successful Cypress kind of
assertion there but one thing I do want
to show you is that
I I don't necessarily want to
just do a side out visit to like this
entire URL each time we can actually
configure a base URL within Cyprus so
I'm going to go to my cyber stock
configure
and within my end to end property here
I'm going to set
a base URL and I'm going to set that to
my localhost
3000 here
so let me grab that
and now I'm going to set my base URL to
HP localhost colon
3 000 and I'm gonna make sure to put a
comma there so my syntax isn't broken
and then within my fundamentals test and
it just re-ran my it reset since I
changed my config it reloaded my Cypress
Runner but I'm going to come back to my
test and now instead of including
localhost 3000 here
I'm going to just go to forward slash
fundamentals now when I changed my it
argument to
contains correct
header text and I'm going to probably
change this title as well because in
Cyprus
it recommends that you don't have a
bunch of small little tests within your
testing Suite as Cyprus does a lot of
work between tests and we'll cover this
more in best practices but Cyprus does a
lot of work between your tests to kind
of clean up different things and add
different things and stuff like that so
it actually takes a little a little bit
longer and it's a little bit less
performant for Cyprus to do these small
individual tests and it's actually
better to kind of write a little bit
longer tests okay so just something to
keep in mind there but
now I just need to visit forward slash
fundamentals since I set my base URL and
my Cypress config and then this should
all still work I believe unless I did
something wrong so if we go back to
fundamentals you see that it does indeed
still work I still go to localhost 3000
as my base URL and then I go to my
fundamentals page here
okay
now
let's go ahead and
I want to
let's let's do a couple of other things
so maybe we'll also like
we can click on this fundamental number
one here and we can assert that it has
that this text exists when we do click
on it but before we click on it we can
assert that this text doesn't exist or
that it's not visible so technically
speaking this text always exists within
our Dom but it's only visible
when we click to open this fundamentals
block number one here okay so we're
gonna get this element we are going to
assert that this text does not it's not
visible
and then we are going to click to open
this describe block and then we're going
to assert that it is indeed visible
and then maybe we'll click on it again
and assert again that it's no longer
visible so we're confirming that this
element does open and close like we
expect Okay so
I think the first thing that we'll have
to do here is well let me inspect this
here which this is why I love Cyprus I
can just inspect my app right here I
don't have to keep going like back and
forth between my browser and different
things like that so I find that to be
super
super helpful so let's go ahead and
if I inspect this first element you see
that it is a it has an ID of panel 1A
header but I do see that so this is
panel 1A header but this one also has
pedal raw to a header and this one also
has panel 1A header so that's not going
to work so we're gonna have to write a
data test ID here or at least that's
what we're gonna do there's different
ways you could do this
but that's how we're going to do it here
so if we go back and
I go to my fundamentals page
as you can see I has all of my items to
my items accordion here so let's go to
this items according component and you
can see that it takes all of my items
and then it Maps over those items and it
returns an individual like accordion
block or every item this is a little bit
react specific so we're not going to
worry about it too much well all that
you're going to need to know here is
that we need to add a data hyphen test
ID
for our accordion item right here so
right here within my outer block I'm
going to do data hyphen test
and it needs to be unique for every item
so all I need to do here is set my data
hyphen test to my item dot ID here
and I'm going to actually do a a
JavaScript string here
so this is just JavaScript specific here
I'm going to say accordion item
and then I'm going to use my item.id
if I now go back to my Cypress Runner I
should be able to see that
this item right now
we should have an element that has a
accordion item one so you see that this
now has a data hyphen test right here of
accordion item one
so I'm gonna get accordion item one
using side I get and then we are going
to open it assert that it has its text
close it assert that that text is no
longer visible so the way that I want to
do this
and the way that I write like to write
tests in general is kind of
incrementally so let's first go back
here let's go to our fundamentals test
here
so we're going to go to our fundamentals
test and
I'm gonna go ahead I'm going to create a
new test here but just know that you
would probably want to make this all in
the same test I'm doing this because I'm
going to show you something using the
before each command here in a sec so I'm
doing this more for example purposes but
as I mentioned from Best Practices
you're probably gonna would want to make
this in a real world situation just one
longer test rather than writing a bunch
of like small little unit tests Cyprus
recommends that you write a little bit
longer test than what I'll be doing here
but we're going to say
that
the accordion Works correct correct Lee
so to do this here we're still going to
visit our fundamentals page
but then we're going to want to get our
accordion
hyphen item hyphen one
okay
and
we're going to click on that element and
then I just want to pause my test and
see where I'm at so I'm going to then
chain on
I'm going to side out click and then I'm
going to call Dot pause
on this so if I go back to my test
Runner
you see that I did indeed click on this
element is it this cool this kind of
makes testing fun I think anyways okay
testing still isn't that fun but it's
definitely a little more fun here so I'm
going to click on this element and then
you see that this element has the text
of your test will exist in a describe
block and then it has some other stuff
so I'm going to copy like the first part
of this
and what I'm going to do is before I
click on this element I'm going to say
psydog contains
and then I'm gonna pass a regular
expression in here
I'm gonna paste in your test will exist
on the describe block
now I'm going to say that this dot
should
not be
visible okay so I'm going to say your
test will exist in the describe block
should not be visible
and then I'm going to click on my first
accordion item here and then I'm going
to make another assertion
and I'm going to say
that this text should
be visible
and I'm no longer going to use this
pause here
so we're gonna go back we're gonna run
this
and we do and see deed see that this
test it does pass because I make an
assertion that before I click on this
element
I can't see this text it's not visible
but then after I click on it it isn't
invisible and now let's also include
if I click on this
element again here so I'm going to copy
this paste it here I'm going to click on
it again so this should close the
element
I'm gonna now say that my text should
not be visible
so let's go ahead and do that I'm going
to say psydot contains this text and it
should no longer be visible
and if I run this here we actually are
going to see it fail here so what I
think is going on is that when it goes
to close this it just clicks on the body
of this text it doesn't actually click
on
this button up here so what we actually
need to do is we need to adjust this
little bit in which we want to make sure
we're clicking on this div that has a
roll of button that is actually nested
within my accordion item one
so let's go ahead and copy
roll equals button here and I'm going to
change my test assertion here instead of
just getting data hyphen test equals
according items one
I'm going to now do I want to also get
within my according item one I'm going
to get my div
that has a rule of button and I'm going
to click on that
and then I'm going to use this assertion
down below here as well
okay
so now if I go back you see it does open
and close it now because I'm clicking on
the button I'm not just clicking on the
text so you have to make sure that
you're making the right query for the
right thing which
Cyprus it's easy to do because you can
just inspect and debug right within how
you would with your normal apps there so
that kind of shows you a little bit of
the fundamentals here of using describe
blocks using itblogs how to navigate
getting different elements clicking on
those elements making your assertions so
with that let me show you a couple of
other fundamentals here in which well we
could just look at these within my test
Runner here so I'm going to close this
but
you can also focus on a single test
so if you just will work on one test at
a time what you can do is you can use it
dot only to just run a single test so
say I'm working on this second test here
I know this test pass and I really just
want to focus in on the second test and
make sure it's working I can just do it
dot only
and then what I chain only on it's only
going to run this single test here as
you can see my testing Suite it no
longer runs my first test it only runs
my accordion works correctly test and
that's um kind of keep in mind as well
is that you're going to see my describe
block is right here my fundamentals test
and then within my describe blog I see
the name of all my it blocks so I'm
going to remove it.only
so now I should see my describe block
fundamentals test I should see contains
correct header text as well as accordion
works correctly so if I go back you see
fundamentals test contains header text
accordion works correctly okay
now with this within our testing box you
can also use a before each command so
like I say you could use before each to
perform certain actions prior to every
test now this can be helpful when you
need to kind of set different things up
for your test so if you want to navigate
to a certain page if you need to use a
certain fixture or inner set which I
will cover here a little bit later on or
you need to do other test setup you
should use a before each now Cyprus also
has an after and after each function but
Cyprus recommends using before or before
each to set things up beforehand I'll
cover why that is in our best practice
section but they do recommend using
before each or before rather than after
or after each and I'll explain why that
is here later on but let's go ahead and
use a before each function
and as you can see
right now I'm kind of repeating
side.visit forward slash fundamentals in
both of these tests so why don't I just
use a before each function into this I
pass a callback function as well I don't
pass a title just a callback function
and I'm going to use
side.visit fundamentals
I'm going to remove that and then I
don't need side.visit fundamentals
within my individual tests anymore
because I'm going to use my before each
year to visit my fundamentals page
before
both of these tests right here so if I
save that and I go back
you should see both of my tests still
correctly pass because I used my before
each block to navigate to my
fundamentals page before each test now
you could use this before you block like
I said for anything that you need to do
to set up your test it's very kind of
useful for those use cases
now the last kind of fundamental I want
to show you and this is by no means the
end of the Cypress course we still got
quite a bit to cover here but I think
that once you have these fundamentals
down you can definitely start writing
your own tests and start really being a
bit more proficient with Cyprus but we
of course are still going to cover best
practices writing component tests some
examples of common use cases covering
forms and so we still got quite a bit to
go here but this is kind of the last
fundamental I want to show you and that
is using custom commands so you aren't
limited to just the PSI dot whatever
commands but you can read your create
your own custom commands and you can add
these commands to Cyprus forward slash
support forward slash commands dot TS or
JS for example you might add a custom
git data command that gets an element by
a data hyphen test attribute so
in our
kind of queries here you see that
for all of our side eye gits here we're
doing square brackets data hyphen test
and then equals fundamentals header
square bracket did hype and test equals
accordion item one so
we're kind of repeating ourselves here
in which we're repeating this data
hyphen test pretty frequently so
wouldn't it kind of be nice to like be
able to use a psydot get by data hyphen
test or psydot git data test so we can
just pass in fundamentals header and
since I had to go a little bit deeper
here with this query we won't actually
use it for these but what if I wanted to
replace this one with my own custom
command So then whenever I'm just
getting an element by its data test I
could just reuse that command well
like I said we can go to my support in
commands.js and we can write just a
single command here by doing something
like this
so the way that we can do this is doing
cypress.means Dot add and we can name
our Command here so I'm going to say git
data test and then all it's going to
take is
a data
test selector
and within the body of this function
here so as you can see this folds a very
similar structure as we've seen before
with Cypress in which we first pass it
the title of our custom Commander and
then as a secondary argument here we
pass a callback function that is going
to be our actual code and all we need to
do here is we're going to return using
the side I get and then we're going to
pass it into JavaScript template literal
here and all we're going to do is data
hyphen test and that is equal to
r
data test selector here so we're writing
a custom command in to write your own
custom command to use cypress.com
commands and call the add method and
then we
use two arguments the first argument is
going to be the name of your custom
command so it's just a string we're
calling this a git data test and then
the second argument is going to be a
callback function that is going to be
actually your code that you want to be
your custom command so in this example
all I'm going to do is I'm going to
return
side.get and I'm going to hard code in
my data hyphen test and then my kind of
dynamic variable here is my data test
selector
so when I call side I get data test
I can pass a data test selector and then
it's going to return side I get this
data test of my test selector so the way
that this works here is if I go back to
my fundamentals page instead of doing
side.get data hyphen test fundamentals
header I can just do
psydot git data test
and I can just pass in
my
fundamentals
header here
and then I'm going to say should contain
text
ing fundamentals and I'm going to remove
this here so instead of needing to
rewrite my data hyphen test every time I
just want to get an element by its test
ID
I can just use this custom command get
data test as in my data test ID or my
data test string here and then use my
insertion that way so if I go back to my
test Runner you see everything still
passes because I wrote my custom command
and it works just like it did before but
now instead of needing to write this
attribute selector for data hyphen test
I can just use this custom command and
we will continue to use this custom
command as we move forward with our
tests and as we do different examples
we'll be able to use this and you'll see
it come in handy more and more here okay
so
just to kind of go over these
fundamentals once again here with Cyprus
you write your tests within a file a
Cypress file and this file is going to
contain a describe block it takes two
arguments the first argument is going to
be a string that is going to be the
title of that describe block and that
string is going to show up within your
testing Suite right within your kind of
spec files here
so if I open this you see I have
fundamentals dot SCI hyphen.js that's
the name of my file name
and then my describe block has my
fundamentals test so I'm testing my
fundamentals page and then within your
describe blocks you're going to have it
blocks
and those are going to be very similar
to describe blocks but they're for your
individual tests which the first
argument to your it blocks is going to
be a string with a name of that
individual test the second argument is
going to be a callback function that
actually contains your test code
okay so you have your scribe blocks and
it blocks
and then you also have different
commands and interacting with elements
in which Cypress gives you the global
PSI object in which you can have
different methods on it like side out
click side.visit side I get all these
different elements to add some different
user actions and to help you with your
testing and then you can get elements
using side.get and then after you get
enrollment you can use command chaining
and make an assertion on those but for
getting your almonds you all you need to
do is pass a CSS query selector as a
string to your side out git and that
will return that element
and then you can make an assertion on it
by doing chaining so side eye kit my H1
element and it dot should contain
certain text or it should have a certain
property so on and so forth and then you
can focus on individual tests by using
it dot only to only run that single test
you can use a before eat function to
perform certain setup actions before
your tests and you can write this at the
very top of your describe block so
before each and then you can pass in a
function for your different code that
you want to set up your test so here we
want to visit our fundamentals page
before all of our tests here and then
with that you can also add your own
custom commands within your support
commands.js using
cypress.commands.add it takes two
arguments the first is going to be the
name of your command so whatever you use
for your string here it's going to be
the name of your command so this is
going to be PSI Dot in this example git
data test but if I called this just
get data then it would be psi.gid data
okay and then the second argument is
going to be a callback function that is
going to be your command code so here I
I expect when I call data git data test
then I'm going to pass it a data test
selector and then I'm just going to
return side.get and then using that data
test selector and then I can use this
within all of my different tests so
those are the fundamentals of Cyprus but
we still got a little ways to go here
let's now move to forms how you can get
forms type into forms test that we
successfully subscribe testing
validation and all that stuff related to
form so let's now move on to that and
what we're going to do is head over to
the forms page and we're basically just
going to test this email input now it
might seem like you know super
straightforward and stuff and it is
pretty straightforward but when it comes
to forms there's actually quite a bit of
different things that we can do with it
in which we can get the form we can type
in the form we can click on the
Subscribe button we can test whether it
was successful or if there's a failure
we can also test validation so there's a
lot of different things that you can do
when it comes to forms so let's go ahead
and write a new test for this form so
heading back to my code editor here
we're going to write another test here
and we're going to go to my Cyprus
folder and then within it we're going to
go to my end to end folder and then
we're going to create a new file here
so I'm going to create a new file and
it's just going to be
forms.sci dot Js
okay and now to write our test here
we're first going to start with a
describe block and then as a first
argument to this describe Block it's
going to be the title of our entire
testing Suite so I'm going to just say
forms
test
or maybe form tests makes more sense and
then we're going to pass a callback
function here
and then within this callback function
this is where we can kind of set up our
test so we're going to go before each
here
and pass a callback function into before
each
and we're going to use side I visit
and we're going to visit our
forms page I believe that's the correct
URL
and then for my first test the first
argument is going to be a string
explaining the test so I I think that we
can do this actually all in one test I
don't think we necessarily need to write
a bunch of individual tests here it can
just be one longer test that tests the
Spore as as like a best practice by
Cypress anyways so we probably wouldn't
have needed to use this before each but
just for more practice kind of getting
the syntax down I think it's fine to do
that and yes I also changed my shirt
it's a different day I record these
videos before I go to work at the
boarding I work a regular like nine to
five job so uh yeah that's the only
reason I don't wear the same shirt every
single day so uh with that we're gonna
test
subscribe form so that's going to be our
title of our test and then we're going
to pass a callback function that's
actually going to be our test code here
so the first thing that we're gonna want
to do is probably
well I think we can first assert that we
are on the correct page so all we need
to do here is I'm gonna assert
that
this page contains testing forms as text
so all we have to do to do that is
psydog contains
testing forms I'm going to pass a
regular expression that is case
insensitive and that is going to assert
that we do indeed go to the correct page
so I'm going to open up my specs here
and we now see a new test here called
forms.sci.js so I'm going to click on
that
and we can see that this runs and it
does indeed pass
so all I do is I visit the forms page
and over here on the left side you can
also see your different assertions so
here I can see side.visit forward slash
forms side out contains testing forms
and it's a regular expression and it
even shows me that it sees testing forms
right here in my page so we see testing
forms and then if I click on this you
can see printed output to the console so
I can also head to my counsel here
and you can see that it prints out my
content of testing forms and it says
it's applied to and it shows me where in
the Dom that is as well so clicking on
this you can print out what it's finding
as your assertion as well which can be
super helpful from time to time
but we asserted that we're on the
correct page so now we want to get this
email input and then type something into
it so to do this let's inspect again and
I think I'm going to want to add a data
test attribute to this so let's go ahead
and do that so back to the code editor
I'm going to go to my forms folder and
my page.jsx within that folder
and then here I have my text field that
I'm returning within my forms page
component all right so on this text
field
I'm going to add a data test attribute
that is going to be sub
scribe
yeah and then going back to my
Cyprus test Runner here reload this page
and I should see on this input
there should be
or on the wrapper of this input there
should be a data test and we do see it
right here so we have a data test right
here and then that wraps around our
input so I think that the way that we'll
do this is we'll get this data test div
here and then we will find the input
within it so let's go ahead and do that
so I'm going to say
back to our
s tier
I'm going to say
psi.get and then I can actually do
side.get
data test
I believe is what we used for our custom
command and then I'm gonna do sub
scribe there
and let's just first make sure that that
does indeed work and it does get the get
the form so yes that does get the form
but now we need to get the input so I'm
going to say dot find
input and now let's see if that works
and that does indeed work so we're
getting the input within D4 but now that
we've gotten this input we actually want
to type something into it so let's let's
first just test the happy path meaning
the user goes through and they put the
correct email in right away and they
successfully subscribe so let's go ahead
and do that here and all we have to do
to type into an input is doing Dot type
and now I'm going to do a valid email
address so I'm going to just say Ryan at
code Ryan dot IO which is actually my my
email address so if I go back here
and I see that I successfully type into
my input Ryan coderion.io so now we need
to go ahead and click subscribe here
so let's add a data test to this
subscribe button so if I go back and I
go to my
page.jsx or my subscribe button here and
add a data test is equal
to
subscribe button here so now we've added
this data test so within our actual test
itself
we can go ahead and
get R side I get
data test
and here you're kind of seeing how this
custom command is coming in quite
helpful here but we're gonna get
subscribe
button and then or going to do with our
subscribe button is we're going to click
on it now we're actually going to get an
error here but I'll I'll show you what's
going on so let's go back
and then we click on the Subscribe
button what we get invalid email Ryan
Ryan solomon.io because what I'm doing
here is
within mypage.jsx I'm just adding some
validation here just for the sake of
example this isn't how you would
actually want to do validation in like a
real professional application as
word is like basically checking two
things and outputting just a little bit
of text right under the uh text input
here so this isn't how you would
actually want to do this but one
validation I'm doing is if it doesn't
include.com it's going to say invalid
email and also if we don't have an input
length it's going to say that it has a
failure message so let's go ahead and
change our
typing just a little bit and let's just
put this as.com this is not my actual
email now this is change so if I go and
I run this test here by reloading this
you're going to see I subscribe and I
get successfully subbed Ryan at
coderion.com so I'm going to run this
again here I'm going to copy the text
quick because I have this message
removed after like three seconds I think
so I think I got it copied there so now
I'm going to say that when I click on it
I should be able to see side out
contains the text of successfully subbed
Ryan coderion.com now I'm going to want
to say that this doesn't exist before I
click subscribe so I'm going to say here
and I'm going to say dot should
not DOT exist
but here I'm going to say dot should
exist so let's go ahead and run this
and we see it successfully run but just
to see it it'll run again here live
we see that we do indeed see
successfully sub so that is a bit of the
happy path and if I keep looking down
here it's because I have another dog
down here at my feet
um it's actually a friend's dog that I'm
watching today so uh I'm not trying to
be rude I'm just making sure I've got
stuff to God the dog down to leg up my
feet so uh with that that kind of works
but now
let's actually test kind of some some
failures here so to do that we're gonna
get this input again and this time
around we're actually going to
type in an invalid email and then assert
that an invalid email message exists now
I'm going to get my form again
using this assertion but what we can
actually do here if I'm going to be
reusing a
certain query a lot or reusing a certain
line of code lot and it's maybe just in
an individual testing Suite I'm not
going to be using it kind of like
applied so like if I was using App wide
I might add a custom command like a
super General kind of command like git
data test I'm going to use this in a
whole bunch of different testing Suites
throughout the application but
if I'm just using something like an
input within a specific test you could
actually create an alias for that and
make things a little bit easier on
yourself so let's actually go look here
at the Cyprus
documentation so this is my localhost
3000 but let's go ahead and look at the
docs and you can actually add aliases
and on this page it actually covers
waiting and retryability as well so
let's cover that as well so
with Cyprus rechriability is a core
feature of Cyprus and having a proper
understanding of it is incredibly
important and I definitely agree with
this so while some other testing tools
require you to add hard weight so like
you add an arbitrary weight for like
three seconds or something to occur
Cyprus gives you different ways to kind
of do this so Cyprus is notified the
moment a page loads and the moment it
unloads it is also notified of any
events that are fired Cyprus is smart
enough to know how fast an element is
animating and will wait for it to stop
animating before you do an action upon
it it also automatically Waits until an
element becomes visible enabled or when
another element is no longer covering it
Cypress will pause execution of any
commands when a page transition happens
and waits until a new page load so
Cyprus kind of automatically does it
will automatically retry for an element
for certain amount of time until it
exists or an animation is done or
something like that so that is a pretty
cool feature of Cyprus I'm not going to
go into too much depth of it because it
kind of happens automatically but it is
something nice to know and before we
cover aliases let's also cover explicit
weight
so they mentioned that even though
Cyprus is incredibly smart not not to
brag in handling automatic waiting there
are times when you explicitly want to
wait for something
for example you want to wait for a
specific Network request to finish and
they mentioned that the best way to kind
of do this is
if you use a network request you can
give it an alias here which we'll talk
about elise's more in a sec and then you
can just wait for that Alias and it will
wait until this network request is done
so instead of just using an arbitrary
weight for a certain amount of time it
might be better to give this request in
Alias and then using side out weight and
passing in that Alias name
is effectively just going to wait until
that request is complete and that's what
Cyprus kind of mentions down here so
that would be a little bit better to go
about this rather than using arbitrary
weights so like waiting for a certain
amount of time but to go back to aliases
here and Cyprus they use aliases to
reference elements requests or
intercepts across tests to create Alias
you can use the as function so here they
get a table they find the table rows and
then they given an alias of a rose so
the next time they go to use this they
can just use side.get and then use an at
symbol rows
so they name a rose here and then you
can just use side I get rows so you
don't have to keep typing all this out
you can just get your Alias so that is
actually what we're going to do here
we're going to use a type Alias for our
input because I don't want to have to
keep typing
this assertion out every time
so I'm gonna just go ahead and
do this
well I'm going to say dot as
then I'm going to say sub scribe
hyphen
input so now instead of
using this I'm going to just say side I
get and then I'm going to use at symbol
sub
scribe hyphen
input and now this should all still work
because I gave it this I gave this git
this label here just this Alias so now I
can just do side I get at subscribe
input and then I type into it so if I go
back
I should see that this all indeed does
still work here
so
now let's go ahead and after this test
completes this message is going to show
for I believe three seconds so we
actually I think in this situation using
in arbitrary weight or a certain amount
of time is actually something that makes
sense here because we want to wait until
this message is removed after three
seconds so I'm gonna actually do side
out weight
and we're going to wait for three
seconds here
and then we're gonna say
that this message no longer exists
after those three seconds so let's go
ahead and see if this works
so going back here
and you see it's waiting for three
seconds my message is removed and then I
assert that it no longer exists so that
is what we want so now let's start
testing in unhappy path so we're gonna
use our Alias again here on paste it
right here
and instead of typing Ryan coderion.com
let's do dot IO
and now we can click on the Subscribe
button again
after this and we should get some sort
of like failure message
so we wait for three seconds
and then we get invalid email right at
coderind.io so let's actually make an
assertion now
that
invalid email exists
after
we hit click so invalid email Ryan
at coderie dot IO that should exist
waiting for three seconds
and then we do indeed get invalid email
right at code Ryan should exist and just
to make sure we're going to make sure
that it doesn't exist before we hit
click as well but I trust that this is
going to work here so we're okay to do
this and yes I'm heading by by dog as
we're going here but
what we can now do is
so we did the not exist let's go look at
the code here so I have
successfully solved we tested the
invalid email here so now let's test
this failure Clause so this basically
occurs if I don't put an email in my
input at all and I click subscribe and
just like we did before here
I'm gonna wait
for three seconds
and then we're gonna say that this no
longer exists
and then we're gonna get
our input here again
but we're we're actually not going to
type anything into it so we actually
don't need to get this input at all we
can actually just click
on our subscribe button with nothing in
our input so let's go ahead and do that
and let's see what we get
so successfully subscribed invalid email
here
and then we get invalid email
explanation point so the way that our
logic is here is if it doesn't
include.com it's automatically going to
uh just show this message here so
I think that the way that we can solve
this is we can actually just put if
we have an input value and
we have our end it doesn't include.com
here then it's going to show this
message
but we just don't have an input value
then it should show fail and this is
just JavaScript here we're just using
okay if there is an input value and it
doesn't include.com show this message
but technically here if it doesn't have
an input value then it should just show
fail here
so if I go back here
and I rerun it we should see fail
for our final test
and then wait for three seconds remove
it and then we do indeed see fail so
let's go assert that fail exists after
this test
so
we're gonna contain this
and then all this should say
is fail but then before this I want to
make sure that bill doesn't exist
to make sure that this is working
properly
so let's go back and all this should now
work and as you can see the forms there
actually is quite a bit that you can
test when it comes to validation and
stuff like that so everything passes
here and we kind of successfully tested
our validation subscribing typing in the
form getting the form and all that stuff
so hopefully that was a good example for
you to kind of learn how to use aliases
as well as some different assertions
like finding the input and more practice
using before each and testing that
things exist or should not exist so I
hope that that was a good example for
you to learn a lot there but now let's
go ahead and move forward into some more
examples in which we're going to touch
on multi-page testing intercepts helpful
message and we also are going to test a
grudge list because you know like a
to-do list is way too boring so we are
gonna have a grudge list to which we're
going to add some grudges and for
example we're going to add Grudge like
some guy
cut me off on my drive today and then
I'm gonna add this Grudge and then you
can see I have the scrudge now
I did add an ability to remove garages
normally we like to hold our grudges and
we don't remove them but for the sake of
testing we are going to remove this so
this will also be kind of a fun example
for us to test so without further Ado
let's move on to this examples page and
we're going to start with multi-page
testing so let's go ahead and open our
end to end folder here and add another
file
and what this is going to be is examples
dot PSI Dot Js
and we're going to write a describe
block here
in which we're going to test our
various
examples
and here we're going to pass a callback
function and our first it block is going
to be multi
page test date
and what we're going to do here is pass
another callback function
and we are just going to side.visit
our base URL here
so right there
and I'm then going to pause the test
here and see the state of our test so if
I go back and I open my examples file
within our Cypress test Runner
you should see that it does just go to
our home page and it stays here and I'm
going to navigate here to our examples
page
and our first example is multi-page
testing so
you can quite easily write tests across
different pages to better test your
entire user workflows you can do this by
clicking on different buttons so I can
click on my navigation buttons here
within my test to navigate to different
pages but I can also use side.visit and
kind of navigate my application that way
which you've already seen me use side
out visit and use that for different
Navigation within my app now when doing
these multi-page tests one thing that
you can do is also make an assertion
that you are at the correct path so you
can use side out location pass in the
path name so it Returns the path name
and then you can use an assertion on
that so should equal and then some Pat
so
let's actually go ahead and do this and
let's actually test our kind of
navigation bar up here click on these
different buttons and assert that we are
at the correct location for these tests
so I don't think that I have a data test
on any of these buttons here so far so
yeah I do not have a data test on these
so let's go back to our application code
here and let's go to our
components here
and then go to our nav bar so you can
see I have all of my nav items here and
then this is just a react thing so I map
over all of my items and then I return a
new nav item element for every item and
this nav item element is just a link
within each ref set on to it
so what I should do here is
wherever item I should add a data test
attribute to it so up here I'm going to
do data test and then I'm going to do
nav
and then y Cyprus
and then I'm gonna copy this and
actually instead of a data hyphen test
I'm going to just do data cable case
test and then I'm gonna paste this down
here
but I'm going to call this
overview I think you probably see where
I'm going with this
I'm gonna do this again
and do
fundamentals here
and then I'm going to do this again
sorry that this is a little bit tedious
but sometimes this is the nature of
writing tests which is also why you know
I don't always love writing tests and I
tend to prefer just developing new
features
but sometimes coding does have some
tedious things that you just have to get
done
so one more here data
test and this is going to be best
practice is so then I need to pass those
to my nav item element so I'm gonna put
these on a new line here just because
I'm passing a few different props and
all I'm going to do is say data tests
equal to
item.data
test and then I'm gonna go to my nav
item
I'm going to destructure my
data test attribute in on my link
component here I'm going to say data
test is equal to
data test
so now if I go back to my Cypress Runner
and I didn't mess anything up you should
see that now these have these all have
a different data test element on them as
you can see here
so now that that is true
within my actual test we need to get
these elements click on them and then
assert that we are at the correct
location within our application so the
way that we can do this here
is I can copy this right here to my test
here so examples.c hyphen spec
in I so I actually don't want to
do why Cyprus first because I'm already
at my home page but maybe
let's actually do this in my before each
block I'm going to navigate to my
examples page first
so I'm going to use a before each
and we're first going to decide that
visit
examples
forward slash examples
and then on
this test right here
I'm gonna actually do
site I get
data test
and I'm going to pass in my nav dot y
Cypress and then I'm going to click on
it
and then I'm going to use that assertion
of this assertion here so I'm going to
copy this
I'm going to paste it so I'm going to do
side out location pass empathname that
should equal
and then I'm going to do it should just
be
my home path here so I'm going to save
this
and it does indeed pass so you can see I
clicked on this and I have element here
and then it navigated me to my home page
here so now I just need to do this for
all of my other components here so this
one's going to be overview fundamentals
forms examples component Etc so
let's go ahead and
I'm going to
copy this
we're going to do nav hyphen
overview and then we're going to serve
that we are on the overview page
and then we're gonna do let's do
fundamentals and assert that we are at
the
fundamentals page
and you guys probably get the gist I
probably don't need to do this for every
single page if you want to you can but
the purpose of this is just to show you
how
multi-page testing can work here and how
you can navigate across pages and assert
that you are at the correct page so
we'll do overview fundamentals examples
why Cypress and make these assertions
using the path name and then I just
refresh the page
you should indeed see that this
multi-page test does indeed work here so
with that that is how you can kind of
set up multi-page testing pretty
straightforward to do but now let's look
at using intercepts in Cyprus so Cyprus
provides you different ways of working
with a network request and one of those
is by using intercept so you can
effectively intercept a network request
that occurs in your application and then
you can return some like example data
and something like this so this could be
helpful in a situation to where like
if you use an external Library like I
don't know Amazon Cognito services for
authentication or something like that
and you want to just like mock that
request and you want to intercept it so
you're not constantly hitting like AWS
during your tests and stuff then you can
use an intercept to do this so let's go
ahead and go to our
guitar application code here and within
this application code
we are going to look at our examples
page here
and you can see that I have this post
button here
and
you can see that in my tests I have this
post button here my examples page and
all this is going to do if we navigate
to it is make a fetch request to
localhost 3000 forward slash examples
and it's going to be a host method and
then it's going to cancel log it's
actually going to just cancel log the
response I'm gonna I'm gonna actually
change this here I probably should uh
done this off of that but we're actually
going to do rats dot Json
not DOT then
we're going to get the data an old
console log the data here
so
we're gonna make a post request to this
but in my tests I don't want to actually
make this post request to my database
and like store stuff in my database I
just want to intercept this post request
and then return some whatever data I
decide to return what we're going to do
here is add another it block and we're
going to do
intercepts is the title
and then we're going to pass a callback
function and
what we're going to do here is we're
going to use a PSI dot intercept
function from Cypress so the first
argument to this function is the method
of that you're going to intercept so get
post put delete patch what method are
you going to intercept so in our case
we're going to intercept a post request
right now
and the next argument is the URL that
we're going to intercept so in my nav or
my post button here I'm going to copy
this URL here
and this is going to be the URL
that we are going to intercept so look
who's 3000 forward slash examples and
then the third argument is what we
actually want to use as our response
here so for now I'm just going to say
in the body of my response I'm going to
return an object in which I'm going to
say the message
is
successfully intercepted request okay
so just to be fully clear here
this post button when we click on it
this post button is right here when we
click on it it's going to make a request
to this Locos colon 3000 examples and
then I am going to
within my test I'm going to intercept
that post request here using Sita
intercept with a post method at this URL
and then I'm going to return a response
that has a body containing a message
saying successfully intercepted request
and we should see that within my console
here because I'm console logging my
response data
so we're going to go back here and I'm
just going to run my intercepts test
here so I'm going to do it dot only and
we're going to focus on this intercept
so now that we have this Intercept in
place what we need to do is click on our
button so
let's add a data test to this button
and I'm going to say post button is all
I'm going to name it so in our test here
all we need to do is I need to side.get
data test and hopefully you're seeing
that we're using this data test all the
time which is why it's so useful to have
this as a Cypress command
but we're going to get the post button
and all we're going to do is click on
that button and within my test here you
see it runs successfully and then just
so I can have a cleaner console I'm
gonna just click post button again but
what you can see is when I hit this
button and I post data I return a
message of successfully intercepted
request so our intercept is working
correctly now what if in your intercepts
you want to actually
instead of just returning some
hard-coded message you want to return
like some some data from a file well the
way that you can do this is using a
fixture so let's actually look at the
docs here
the Cyber stocks on intercepts so just
like what I explained to you here a
little bit below you can use the psydot
intercept method you can pass in the
method you're intercepting as well as
the URL name and then you can also give
it an alias like it's doing here so
they're intercepting this and they're
calling that the as intercept here
and then you can use a just like we
talked about with weights earlier you
could use a weight for this request to
finish so if you want to intercept a a
sign up request and you just want to
mock that and you don't want the rest of
your test to continue running until that
signup is complete or that request has
resolved you could just use side.weight
passing your Alias for your intercept
there and it will wait until this
request occurs which can be super useful
to do
now here below
let's go down and show their example of
fixtures so here they intercept a get
request and they return a fixture of
public
transactions.json so they just return
this fixture file and the way that you
can do this is you can add a fixture
file to your fixtures folder that cipres
automatically created for us all ready
but before I get to that I just want to
touch on a couple more things on this
page so within your intercepts if you
were to modify the headers from a
response you can do that just like
they're doing here so earlier my third
argument my intercept I passed a body
and I made the body this right here
message successfully intercepted request
but you could also adjust the headers so
pass a header's property and adjust
those there and you can modify the
response data just like it's doing here
very similar to kind of what I did
earlier
and then you can also inspect the
request and you can add more kind of a
logic within it so if the body of the
request contains a certain property you
can reassign it to something else you
can sign into something else so you can
add a lot of logic in your intercepts
just like it's doing here but generally
speaking D it works very similarly to
how we kind of did it here and I would
say if you are trying to figure
something out with your intercept you
can probably do it I would just come to
your docs and consult them here but
let's go back to the fixtures
and look a little bit closer on how this
works so back to our code editor here
you can see that Cyprus automatically
adds a fixtures folder for us so within
our Cypress folder we also have a
fixtures folder
and within that folder that's where we
can add different fixture files and
fixture files are typically files of
like Mock and data that you can use
within your tests so
we have within our fixtures in
example.json
file and this is just a Json file that
has a name email and body property which
is some example data within it So within
my Cyprus test here what if I want to
return this fixture well instead of
returning body as a property here I can
actually return a property called
fixture
and then I can just return
example dot Json
so now if I go back here and I'm going
to clear my console and I'm going to
click post data you can see that my data
in now is my fixture so my body is
fixtures are great uh mock data for
responses just like I talked about
earlier and then it has the email and
the name that it has also in my
example.json fixture file so if you want
to return some mock data and you want to
kind of intercept a request and return
that you can just set a property called
fixture and point that to your file
within your fixtures folder so I could
have another file within this fixtures
folder called
response.json or example response.json
and all I would do if I wanted to return
that is set a fixture property to
example response.json
and as long as I add that within my
fixtures folder here Cypress
automatically knows what I'm trying to
do here okay
so that is how you can use fixtures and
intercepts within your tests to kind of
mock some data mock some different
requests and responses and things like
that so you know this we're not really
doing many like assertions in this test
this is really just to show you how you
can do intercepts use them alongside
fixtures and that sort of thing within
your programs okay so those are super
useful use them all the time in a kind
of real world application which you just
creating like kind of a demo application
like this you don't see this as much but
if you have an application where you're
making several API calls to different
providers and stuff like that
you're probably going to be using
intercepts and returning fixture files
within your test it can be a little bit
tricky when you're first seeing it but
it is really straightforward all I'm
doing is using side.intercept to
intercept a request it can be a post get
put patch and then you pass in the URL
and you just need to match the URL of
that request and then you can return
whatever you want as a response and then
you can also manipulate
in the headers or you can modify the
response data like this using
request.continu and then adjusting it
this way or you can use other
conditionals within this kind of third
argument here to the The Intercept that
you use okay and then you can also use
fixture files by just adding a fixture
or file within your fixture folder that
Cypress automatically gives you already
and then you can just set a property
of fixture
to whatever your file name is within
your fixtures folder okay
so hopefully that gives you a good idea
of fixtures but our next example here is
and this is really just going to be
going over this part of their
documentation in which they talk about
some helpful methods as I don't think
it's particularly useful for you to
learn
every single method that exists within
Cyprus like that that would not be a
productive use of your time however
there are a handful of methods that I do
think are good for you to know that they
exist and that they are available to you
that you can use and that I often use
them a lot in my own test writing all
right
so let's actually go to this page in
their docs here in which we go to Cyprus
methods that you need to know so the
first one is the dot it's method so this
is a very kind of Handy method in which
say you have like a array that you get
from your Dom so you get an array and
this array has these kind of two names
you can use the dot it's method to get
the kind of first index of that array so
they have this array here and then they
are asserting that the element at the
first index of this array so with zero
base indexing that would be this string
here that is y u they're saying that
should equal y u
but you can also use it like this is
pretty useful but it's even more useful
when you use it with properties so here
you can see they have a object with an
age of 52 so if they get an element with
an age of 52 from the Dom they can see
that it's age so of this object get the
property that has an age and then that
should equal 52.
which if you have like a kind of more
more complex object and you want to get
the property from it this this can be
super useful here
and then additionally to that you can
also get kind of nested responses so
here it's getting your response from
this public transactions request and
then it's saying okay dot it's
response.body.results so it's going
nested in here it's getting the response
property on this public transactions
response here and it's going into the
body and then it's getting the results
property on it so you can use the it's
method to access different properties or
different indexes of an array within
your kind of elements that you return
from like a site I get or a response
like they're doing in this example here
okay so the it's method can be super
useful here but you can also use the
invoke method so this allows you to
invoke a function on a previously
yielded subject at the end of the day
Cyprus is just JavaScript and the sidot
invoke method allows you to call
JavaScript functions on JavaScript data
types so an example of what this looks
like is if they get this response that
has
response.body.results and that is a
array well they can dot invoke the slice
method on that array and then they can
pass in the arguments of 0 and 5. so
just like on in JavaScript
if you want to use the slice method on
an array and you want to slice from the
zeroth index to the fifth index well you
can do that in Cyprus by if you yield an
array within Cyprus so here they're
using the its method that we just
covered and they are yielding the
response.body.results that is an array
well they can then invoke the slice
method on that array by calling dot
invoke here and they pass in the
arguments of 0 and 5. this will invoke
the slice method with the arguments of
zero and five so you can use the invoke
method to invoke different JavaScript
functions that you return on your
yielded subjects within Cyprus also a
very useful thing that you can do here
and hopefully this example is is clear
on how you can do that
now alongside that you can also make
HTTP requests in Cyprus using the
request method now I personally don't
use this a ton in the test that I write
but every once in a while this this does
come in handy so request is a helpful
method anytime you need to make an HTTP
request within your tests and perform
expectations against it so here you can
see they use side out request they use a
post method and then they post to this
URL
and then they pass in an object with
some different data on it so you can use
the request method in Cyprus to make
different requests within your test this
actually is a pretty similar API as like
a a fetch method which you could do you
know in JavaScript you can do fetch a
certain URL and then you can pass in an
options object it's a little bit similar
to this except for it works a little bit
more similar to Cyprus intercepts in
which the first argument is the method
so get post put delete and then the
second argument is the URL you want to
make that request to and then you can
add some different options to it like
that so definitely something that is
useful to know here on how to make
different requests within your Cypress
tests using side out request then the
final one we'll look at here
is the dot within method so the scope's
all subsequent Cypress commands to
within an element so say you're using a
form and then you just want to kind of
like drill down into its child element
you can use within to limit the scope of
Cypress commands to within a specific
element so here they get this element
here and they say within that element
you should have a lessons complete of
zero or an element that has a lesson's
complete hyphen zero so I think in even
potassium better example is say you get
a form within your web page and you want
to get certain inputs within that form
but you don't want to make your queries
to
elements that are outside of that form
like you don't want to accidentally be
getting an input that is maybe in your
nav bar and maybe it's a search input
within your nav bar but you also have a
search input within your form and you
just want to get the one within your
form well you could use this dot within
method to only focus your queries or
your Cypress commands on the element
within your form and this this can be
helpful for when
if you're running into a Cypress air
that says it'll say something along the
lines of you cannot make this assertion
on multiple elements you only expected
one element often this occurs when
you're trying to make a Cyprus command
on
elements that you didn't think you were
trying to make that command on and
that's often done because you're not
limiting the scope of that command and
if you use this dot within you might be
able to use this to make sure that
you're not running into the air and
you're only making these assertions or
these commands on elements within other
elements so if you're finding yourself
needing to drill down into the children
of an element you could use the dot
within method to kind of scope your
tests a little bit better there but with
that let's now move to an additional
example here of our Grudge list so let's
actually just kind of go and test our
our Grudge list here which we have right
here so we have a grudge list in which
we can add grudges and then we can
remove them so I'm going to close my
inspector there and then I'm just gonna
say some Grudge and I'm going to add a
grudge and you can see it gets added
I've add Grudge and I can remove it and
you can see the tech exchanges and stuff
like that so let's actually start
writing some tests for this just to test
some kind of different states within
Cyprus and to test some different state
changes so
let's go back to our examples test and
then I'm going to do it and I'm going to
do it dot only again and then I'm going
to name this just grudges
and then we are going to write our test
so we should already be at the example
page and when we
get to our example page here I'm going
to just side out pause here for a sec
let's go back
so this when we don't have any garages
down here it should say add some grudges
so let's now assert that
PSI dot contains and then we're going to
do add some grudges here
and then we'll make sure that this works
so we're basically asserting that before
we have any grudges we have add some
grudges so let's now
inspect this
and
so it's an input
and it doesn't really have like a great
great way to select this so let's add a
data test to this Grudge input here
So within my components I have a grudge
list
and here's my text field here
and let's go ahead and add a data
hyphen test
and that's going to equal
my grudge
list
actually it's more of just like a garage
input is better to call that so
now if I open this up a little bit more
I should see that I have my grudge input
on this div right here but I want to
make sure to select my input here so
what I can actually do here is let's use
a side out within to select this input
so I'm going to do
within my Cypress test
I'm going to say side I get
data test
and I named it garage I think I named it
Grudge input I'm going to say dot Within
I'm going to call this
and I'm going to pass a function to it
and then I'm going to say side dot just
a regular site I get
then I'm going to get an input and I'm
going to type in that input
some Grudge
so let's see if that works here and you
can see it does so this is an example of
I get my My overall Grudge like text
field here so if I inspect this here
I get my overall Grudge text field here
but I want to get the input within my
grudge text field so I don't want to
concern myself with all other inputs
that might occur on this page in this
example there are no other inputs that
occur on this page but say there were I
didn't want to concern myself with those
I can use a side out within and just
pass in an input and I'm only concerning
myself with the inputs within my grudge
input here so hopefully that shows a
good example of how that kind of helpful
method works there
but now that we have this we need to
definitely add
our Grudge here
so here
I have my ADD Grudge button
and
it also does have a great way to query
it so let's go ahead and add a data test
to my
add Grudge button which exists right
here so I'm going to do data hyphen
test equals add
Grudge button and I might spell it
Grudge correctly at all these I sure
hope I am actually not too sure but
below our previous git data test we're
going to do side I get data test and I'm
it's gonna be my ad garage button and
then I'm gonna dot click
on that button here
so you can see I have now called my
click method on my ad guards button and
I've indeed added some Grudge here so
let's see here I have a UL that has my
list item in here so I think the best
way to do this is to actually say that
my UL here contains one list item after
I add my grudge so let's go ahead and go
back to my grudge list
and so I'm always rendering this
unordered list here
but then I'm mapping over all of my
grudges and rendering them as a list
item so let's add a data test here which
is equal to and this one I will actually
call my garage hyphen list
like so I'm going to go back to my test
and I'm gonna say
before I click on my ADD button
and really before I type anything in I'm
going to say side.get
data test
and I'm going to get my grudge list and
then I'm going to call my DOT within
method
and then within my grudge list I'm going
to use psydot
get and then I'm going to get all of my
list items and I'm going to say dot
should
has
length of zero so I should not have any
items within my grudge list when I first
start this test but after I click click
down here
then it should have a length of one
because I should have added one list
item so let's save this and see if this
works here
and it does so you can see within my
kind of History here I first when I just
render this page I see my list items I
have zero but then after I add a grudge
here my list items and now has one
so let's do the same thing and when I
add another Grudge my list items should
now have two here so let's go ahead and
I'm going to copy this here and you
could add this as like a custom command
and have it be like add to Grudge list
or something like that but we we already
showed you custom commands so we're not
going to do that here but let's get our
Grudge input again and then I'm going to
say that instead of some Grudge
I'm going to say that this one is number
two I don't know and then we're going to
click the add button and then we're
going to use side.get data test
and this time we're going to say that it
now has length of two let's copy this
and paste it below so I'm going to do
shift option down arrow and that's going
to duplicate this into another line here
I'm going to get my lies again but here
let's actually use the it's method and
let's get our first list item so the
zeroth index I'm going to say that
should
have text
and that text should be some
Grudge
so let's go ahead and see if that works
here and you see that I put a typo it
here because it says expected Li to have
text some Grudge but the text was some
Grudge X so it's actually not not a typo
here so the way that I render this out
within my
my grudge list is for every list item I
actually render out a span that has my
text and then I render out a button that
has X next to it so
I think a better way to actually do this
is instead of have text let's do
contains text I think that that will
will actually work here and it does so
as you can see here I now have both of
my grudges that have been added and
within our tests we are using the dot
within method here so showing you that
helpful method and then we're also using
the it's method to get the zero with
element of my list items saying it has
the text of some Grudge
so now
let's go ahead and we should click on
the X element of our of one of our
grudges and then we should assert that
in my list actually now has a length of
one and then we should click the clear
button and assert that it has a length
of of zero so it clears them all out
so to do this let's use the inspector
here and is there a good way
that I can query for this x so I
actually think that we can
so what I'm going to do here is within
this list item here this is just a
button so I think we can use the within
method here again I'm going to copy this
here
paste it below I'm going to get my
grudge list
and I'm going to remove this
and I'm going to get my first list item
here I'm going to use the dot it I'm
going to get my first list item
and then I think I can say dot within
again
and then within my first list item I
should be able to side I get
my button
and then I should click on that button
because that should remove and this
particular list item
and then I'm going to copy this and
paste it below now that I remove that
list item it then should have a length
of one my elements I'm going to remove
that secondary one
so let's go ahead and run this
and you see it does indeed pass I'm
going to just run it again just to make
sure
so you can see I removed that first
Grudge and it still works so what I did
here is I got my grudge list here
and then within my overall UL Grudge
list I got all of my list items I got my
first list item using the dot it's
method and passing in a zero so the list
item at the zeroth index because this
side I get will return an array of all
my list items
and then within that first list item
using the dot within method I get my
button and I just click on it and that
button is going to be my my my X element
to remove that particular list item and
then I then assert that my list has
shrunk down to one now let's just click
the clear button and assert that we have
cleared all of our items
so
okay so this is interesting here in
which I'm only rendering my clear button
after my grudge list is over zero so I
have a grudge so
let's do a data hyphen test is equal to
clear button and I'm going to move this
to another line here
just so you can see it a little bit
better and this looks ugly normally I
would have prettier installed it would
do this for me automatically definitely
recommend using prettier
but what I'm going to do here is within
my test
at the top of my test before I have any
grudges I'm going to also do side I get
data test I'm going to say clear button
that should
not exist so I'm going to say that it
doesn't exist when I start my test end
my grudge list has a length to zero
but then here at the end of my test
I'm going to say side.get
data
test and I'm going to say clear
button and then I'm going to dot click
on that button and
I don't need to remake an assertion here
saying it exists because just trying to
click on this button
it's going to have to exist so I'm
implicitly saying that it exists here by
trying to click on it so I'm not kind of
being redundant with my assertions there
and then I'm going to get my grudge list
here again
and all I'm going to do is say it has a
length of zero now after I've cleared my
list
and if I run this everything does indeed
pass here
so
I think that that pretty well tests are
kind of Grudge list here I think that
actually let me let me check one more
thing I'm going to add some Grudge here
again
and it does change the text here to
grudges
so what we can do is we can also test
this here quickly so
let's go back here
and go to our Grudge list this will be
the last thing we test here
in which I do data hyphen test is equal
to
Grudge list
title
and then what we're gonna do is
this you can see that this title here if
my grudges is greater than zero my title
is going to be grudges else it's going
to be add some grudges so to test this
logic here
I'm going to do
at the top of this once again I'm going
to do side I get
data test
I'm going to do Grudge list
title
I'm going to say that should
I'm going to say have
text
of I think it's just add
some grudges
and then here
after I've added a single Grudge here
so right here I know that my grudges has
a length of one I'm going to just assert
that this title now says grudges just to
test it make sure that that logic is
working correctly and you do indeed see
that it passes here so with that that
has tested our Grudge item component I'm
sure there's other things that you could
do here for this but hopefully that
gives you a good idea of how you can
kind of use some of those helpful
methods that we went over here in
example three
and how you can use intercepts
multi-page testing and different things
like that but we aren't quite done here
as now we still need to cover our
component tests how you can write those
and then we will move on to some
different best practices now to
transition into component testing here
what we're going to do is I'm gonna
actually head back to my code editor
here
and this terminal is where I ran the
command of MPX Cyprus open and I was
checking to see if radar docked by light
over there he's blocking it a little bit
but uh oh well so this is the terminal
to Iran MPX Cypress open I'm actually
going to kill this terminal with control
C
and then you can see I
killed this process here and let me
clear this so you can see I have it
right here and then I'm going to reopen
Cyprus so I'm going to do MPX
Cyprus
open here again
and this time around we're actually
gonna go component testing and just like
with end-to-end testing this is
automatically going to configure our
project for component testing so I'm
going to click this
and it detected that I'm using next.js
so I'm just going to go next step
and then it says you've successfully
installed all required dependencies and
then I'm just going to click continue
here
and then you can see it's going to add
all these different files within our
project
so we're gonna just go ahead and click
continue here
so it's initializing everything and
we're going to start component testing
here in Chrome
and it sees that we don't have a
component test here so I'm going to do
create new spec
and then we're gonna test our accordion
component so that is the component in
which for my course notes if I click on
one of my notes and it opens it up it
shows like my notes for that and then we
click on it again it closes it we're
going to write a component test for that
so I think the spelling on this is
like so accordion
and I'm going to create that spec
and we'll do okay run spec
so here
let's go back to our project and see
what we've done here so
if I
close this close this and then we go to
our Cypress folder here
you can see that I now have a folder
within my Cypress folder called
component and that is where my component
tests are going to be and I'm going to
close my terminal here
so this is going to be where my
component tests are
so I'm going to click on my
accordion.side.jsx this is what Cypress
just added here was this component
folder as well as we created this
component test file and if I wanted to
write more component tests I'll just add
another file within this component
folder and it would be the name of my
component and then dot side dot jsx is
how I would write more component tests
but we open this file we see
luckily in Cyprus component tests very
similar to end end test so there's
actually not much new stuff that we need
to know here we still have R describe
blocks and our Intuit as we still have
our it blocks that work the same way as
well so really not a ton else to learn
here and we also use the same kind of
assertions that we do in end-to-end
testing and different things like that
but there are a couple of things
regarding
these component tests that are useful to
know so let's actually head back to our
project here at Locos 3000 I'm not
close this Cypress Runner and let's go
over to component here and I'm going to
open up the first note here so
as I kind of alluded to Cyprus also
allows you to test individual components
in your app via component testing now
why would you do this well Cypress
component testing uses the same test
Runner commands and API so like I said
there's not a bunch of new stuff that
we're gonna have to learn here you start
writing component tests
however the main difference is that
Cypress component testing builds your
components using a development server
instead of rendering within a complete
website which results in Faster tests
and fewer dependencies on infrastructure
than end-to-end tests covering the same
code paths so
that might sound like a lot that is
basically just saying that hey when you
write a component test you are just
testing that component test you don't
have to worry about like logging into
your application or having some sort of
authentication or you don't have to like
go down this login and navigation and go
through this code path just to get to a
certain component and maybe you have a
component that you want to test that is
only available to you when you're
creating a new account with your overall
application but you don't want your your
end-to-end test to be creating new
accounts all the time so maybe you write
a component test so there are use cases
and when component tests are very useful
and for these component tests
they're useful for when you don't want
to go down an entire code path you don't
want to have any dependencies on your
infrastructure or logging in or
authentication and you just want to
write a test for a component in
isolation that's when you would use a
component test and like I said the API
for these is very similar to end tests
our assertions are similar we use
describe blocks it blocks stuff like
that now for additional configuration
here
you depending on your project you may
have to add more configuration to your
kind of Cypress config but luckily
Cypress he usually does this
automatically for you but sometimes you
have to add additional configuration so
if we go back here and we go to our
Cypress config.js you can see I now
within my Define config here that I'm
exporting from this file Cyprus is now
added a component property here and it's
setting a Dev server property within my
component object and it's setting the
framework as next and the bundlers
webpack So within next.js you have to do
something like this to your config to
start writing component tests now this
can change depending on whether you're
using angular view vanilla JavaScript
something like that so you might have to
do some configuration mainly on your own
but Cyprus is pretty good about
detecting that sort of thing and adding
this for you because here it just added
it for us here all right but just keep
in mind that this config file this is
where you can add other configuration
things which can be helpful I know that
in our professional application we do
use some code in this setup node events
to
use some different tasks and stuff like
that but that's a little bit more
advanced than what we're gonna kind of
get into today
but if I go back here
you might have to do some additional
configuration like I said and then also
within your component test I would say
maybe one of the biggest like just
syntax differences is that instead of
like initially visiting a page and then
navigating around your application
you're actually just going to mount a
component using psi.mount and then you
can just interact and make assertions
just as you would with an end-to-end
test so
like I say here let's go test our
accordion so I'm going to go back here
and
if I go to my
accordion.side.jsx you can see that
Cyprus is already added this side out
mount
so what I'm going to do here is I have a
component called accordion right here so
we're going to mount this accordion with
some different items and make some
assertions for it so I go back to my and
I actually call it items accordion so
I'm going to uncomment this and I'm
going to render
my items accordion and automatically
import that for my components folder
and then close that there but I do need
to pass in items
array here
in which
and I need to put that in curly braces
here
but I'm gonna go to I think my
fundamentals page maybe and I'm going to
grab some items here so I'm going to
just copy this
items array
go back to my accordion
and then above my test I'm going to set
these items I don't think we need to
have eight of them let's maybe just do
three of them and then I'm going to set
my items prop here to my items
so I'm just mounting this and I'm gonna
say
that this is my items
accordion
and then I'm going to go back here and
you can see that within my Cypress
Runner it now mounts my items accordion
here
in which I have my three kind of
fundamentals here and now I can write
component tests for this without needing
to worry about
signing into my application
authentication and stuff like that I can
just test and make sure that my
accordion just this component is working
correctly by mounting it to my page here
just rendering it to my page and then
making some different assertions so
let's go ahead and do that so if I
inspect this here
let's see what makes sense to kind of go
about testing but I think I want to
assert that I have three items here so I
think I want to let me go to my items
accordion and for this rapper div
I'm gonna give it a data test here
and I'm going to do data test is equal
to
accordion hyphen wrapper so now in My
overall test and I'm going to go back to
my
accordion side.jsx
but in my test now it should wrap my
items
in a accordion rapper div so we see this
accordion wrapper
and then within that I have three divs
that are my accordion items so what I
can do here is I can make our first
assertion here just like I kind of
normally would to where I can do PSI git
data test so I can still use my custom
Cypress commands within my component
test here and I can do accordion
wrapper
and then I'm going to say dot within
just like we've done before and then
within this accordion wrapper I need to
get all of my divs that start with a
data test so they should have a prefixed
accordion item and then some ID so the
way that I want to do this is I'm going
to do psi.get
and then I need to get
a
data test
and I think it's going to be up arrow
equal sign and then accordion item so
this is saying get all elements that
start with accordion item SE data test
which should be able to select my three
items
and I believe I should be able to do you
should have a length
of 3 here
so if I go back to this it does look
like it ran successfully so if I run it
again it does indeed work so I'm
asserting that it has three items and
now
I think all all we need to do here
additionally is maybe get the the first
accordion item so accordion item one
here and then we can open it assert that
it has its expected tests and then close
it and assert that that doesn't exist
just kind of how we did before and
let me actually we'll we'll go ahead and
write this so
let's do
side I get data test
and then we'll get accordion item one
then we say dot click
so that should open it and
before we do that we should first say
that
your test will exist in the describe
block
we should say that that is not visible
so we'll do PSI dot contains
your test will exist and it's describe
blog that should
not DOT
e Dot visible
but then
after we click it
it should be visible
so we'll remove not there
and then we'll click it again
and then we'll assert
and it's not visible again just to kind
of test that our accordion opens and
closes as expected and we did the same
thing that we did earlier so I need to
make sure that I am
clicking on my button within my
according item and not just my paragraph
text we did this exact same thing
earlier so I need to do I'm going to get
that item number I'm going to dot Within
and then I'm going to say
side I get
my button and it's actually not a button
here it's a div with a roll equals
button so we need to do a attribute roll
is equal to button here
and I believe that this should work and
then if we copy
this and paste it
here I believe this will now pass and it
does indeed pass so here you can see
that to write component tests within
Cyprus all you need to do is run the
Cypress nkx Cypress Open click configure
component test and then it will
automatically add this component folder
as well as some configuration to your
Cypress config.js and then within your
component folder all you need to add is
a file that is dot sci.jsx or TSX
Furious and typescript and then you
could write your describe an IT blocks
just like you normally would but you can
use sideot mount to mount whatever
component you want to test and then
write your assertions just like we've
been doing this whole time so most stuff
with component tests really doesn't
change you still use your describe in it
blocks and normal assertions that you've
learned throughout this course but all
that's different is you mount your
individual component and then you don't
have to worry about logging in
authentication and different things like
that and of course you add them within
your component folder that will create
for you alright so really I think that
covers component tests I don't think
there's much else we need to spend time
with here considering it is so similar
to end-to-end tests that you've already
learned there alright so
next up here and the final section for
us to cover is actually just going
through some different best practices
here so the first one that I want to
talk about and all these best practices
are recommended from Cyprus this is not
necessarily just me with my experience
although I I do agree with these best
practices after using Cyprus for the
last few years so number one is making
sure to test unhappy pads so don't just
test the happy path of the user Make
sure to test how the user might
maliciously use your application or just
unexpected paths that they go down like
if you learn programming sometimes the
user will do some things that you
definitely do not expect so if you have
a certain input that you're writing
tests for don't just test that they
perfectly type their email in correctly
make sure to test that they you know
forget to put a.com on the end of their
email that they don't use enough
characters that they put a phone number
in for their email that they try to
write a scripting command in your email
try to test all these different things
and really try to consider
the non-happy paths and this is also
true when you're like developing new
features you want to make sure that
after you add a new feature you don't
just test that it works with the happy
path really try to break that that
feature and really try to find different
bugs okay so when testing make sure to
test the unhappy paths as well as the
happy paths also Cypress recommends
using stable selector so we talked about
this a little bit before and we've been
doing this throughout this entire course
but using data attributes to provide
context to your selectors and isolate
them from CSS or JavaScript changes is
what Cyprus recommends so don't Target
elements based on CSS attributes such as
IDs classes or tags and don't Target
elements that may change their text
content and also don't use too generic
of selectors so just using side I get
button and selecting all of your buttons
within your entire application probably
not a good idea however maybe you use
side I get a certain data test selector
and then within that you get the button
like we've done throughout this course I
think that's much more reasonable
because you're you're still scoping that
selector it's not too generic
and then also don't couple your
selectors to Styles so effectively what
it's saying here is that to prevent
yourself from just having flaky tests
and for your tests breaking because of
reasons that aren't related to actually
like undesirable Behavior
make sure to use stable selectors which
in a lot of cases it's going to be those
data test attributes that we've been
adding this entire time
and you know making sure I have these in
isolation from CSS in JavaScript changes
as you don't necessarily just want your
has to fail because uh CSS class changed
its name like
I know we we made the mistake before in
our professional application to in which
we would use material UI components and
material UI would change the class name
of their components and then it would
break our tests when in reality it
didn't change the user Behavior it
didn't actually change our app at all
but it broke our test and you definitely
don't want that occurring so make sure
that you are using stable selectors such
as data test attributes and make sure
that you're not coupling your selectors
to Styles not using two generic
selectors not coupling it to different
things like that additionally Cypress
recommends not assigning return values
so we already went over this in the docs
here earlier so we're not gonna go there
again but
we already discussed that Cyprus it has
an asynchronous nature so it does not
run synchronously and assigning things
to return values isn't doing what you
expect it to so you probably shouldn't
be using like variables like side.get
and assigning that to a certain variable
within your test it's probably kind of
an anti-pattern from Cyprus and it's
much better to use just like a DOT then
if you absolutely need to but as you
could see in most of the tests that we
wrote here we actually didn't need to do
anything with DOT thens or stuff like
that we can just use the typical say
purse chaining and everything works just
fine there so try not to assign return
values in almost most circumstances I
want to say all circumstances but I
tried out to be two
um kind of all or nothing about things
but Cyprus does not ruin synchronously
all right and if you need more help
there you can go back to the doc store
where we kind of looked at that earlier
and then also Cypress recommends not
testing external sites so only test
websites you can control and try to
avoid testing third-party servers if you
choose you can use the side out request
that we talked about earlier to talk to
third-party servers via their apis but
if possible cache the results using a
Cypress session to avoid repeat visit so
in Cyprus you can create a session which
you can keep that session active so you
don't have to keep calling these
external servers and generally speaking
I think it's a big mistake in your
testing to test like external libraries
like you don't you don't probably need
to worry about testing AWS Cognito or
testing that a material UI component
works correctly like if you just import
a material UI component and you're using
that component in isolation without any
wrappers around it or additional logic
you probably don't need to go write
component tests for that material UI
component
like you can probably trust that that
component is already tested and missing
can be true for using third-party
servers and external websites and stuff
like that I'll keep your tests within
things that you can control rather than
trying to do these complex things of
testing external sites and stuff like
that
additionally make sure to keep your
tests independent meaning you don't want
one test in your testing Suite to rely
on another one this becomes extremely
difficult to make it trust me so yes I
do have experience of this when we were
first setting up Cyprus we had some
people on our team that were new to
Cyprus and I was new to it as well
and we did have some tests in our
testings we are into a testing Suite in
which in one of our tests we would
create a user for our system and then
the following test in our testing Suite
would expect that user to exist and it
would use that user throughout our tests
however if the test that created a user
failed it would cause this chain
reaction and cause a bunch of other
tests to fail so out of nowhere we would
see like seven different tests fail and
we wouldn't really like understand why
so many tests were failing but
it was because this Chain Reaction
occurred in which one test depend on
another which depended on another and
you definitely don't want to do this and
makes things much more difficult to
manage so make sure that all tests pass
in isolation and do not bleed into in
effect other tests you don't want to
have your tests have side effects into
other tests
and then also I mentioned this earlier
but don't worry about writing tiny tests
so writing tiny tests like unit tests is
non-performant and excessive this comes
straight from Cyprus Cyprus resets
various States and tests between tests
that takes a long time
so small tests kind of her performance
because you write a small test and then
Cypress has to clean up all that state
and do some other things between tests
that take a long time and then at War on
another small test and it'll do all the
stuff that takes a long time then
another test so that can hurt your
Performance Plus within your end-to-end
test you still know exactly what
assertion fails so
it's not like just your your entire test
fails and you don't really know what
fails which if it was a longer test it
would be kind of hard to know in Cyprus
you know exactly what assertion fails we
saw that in our test Runner earlier in
which if an assertion fails we can see
what assertion fails we can go to that
line and start debugging there it's not
like we only know that okay this test
file failed and we have to figure out
what failed within it no you know the
assertion that fails and then since
these small tests can hurt performance
and there's more cleanup that occurs
between tests and it can take a long
time then it's important to not just
focus on writing all these tiny kind of
unit tests and then we also talked about
this one a little bit prior but
Cypress working buttons that you clean
up State before you run tests instead of
using like an after each block or
something like that in which they they
mentioned don't clean up state with
after or after eat one benefit of Cyprus
is incrementally writing tests and
application code and if the state isn't
maintained after a test it can make it
more difficult to know what you should
test next so for example when I was
running our tasks earlier in our test
Runner a test would complete and then I
would inspect the Dom and I would look
at okay what should we text test next
but if you're cleaning up all of your
state after a test then when your test
stops it's going to clean everything up
and I'm not going to be able to use my
application to really know what I should
text test next
so using these after or after each could
get in my way of trying to do that
and then also if something fails in the
middle of a test the after each cleanup
functions won't get a chance to run and
with that Cyprus already cleans things
up between tests anyways so this might
not be something you need to worry about
at all so
with these points here if something
fails within the test here after blocks
don't get a chance to run so you should
probably do any of this stuff before you
start a test anyways and then also
Cyprus also
already does some cleanup and different
state clearing between tests so you
might need not need to even worry about
writing these different cleanup
functions and stuff like that either
before or after a test anyway all right
so generally speaking try to do like
your cleanup and your setup in your
before each blocks rather than doing
things kind of after test completes
and then finally Cyprus recommends not
to use arbitrary side out weights when
possible and to instead use route
aliases to do that sort of behavior so
like we talked about earlier when you
are kind of intercepting route in Cyprus
you can give it an alias using dot as
and then some sort of keyword to kind of
name that request and then later your
tests you can do side out weight and
then you can use the at symbol and then
passing your Alias there and that will
effectively wait for that specific
request to finish so instead of just
using a arbitrary weight which can
become flaky in those situations it
would be better to use an alias and wait
for that specific request to complete by
passing in side out weight and then the
at symbol and your Alias there okay
so those are like eight different best
practices recommended by Cyprus and
ideally do notice right now that I have
a spelling error in recommended oh maybe
you noticed that the entire time
um maybe I will push a change to the
project here so that is fixed but I'm
not gonna worry about it too much if
you've been with me this entire time so
with that thank you so much for checking
this out hopefully you learn a ton about
testing your JavaScript applications
using Cyprus we covered the fundamentals
of Cyprus why you might use it how to
test forms different examples component
tests and some best practices here so
like I said thank you so much for
checking this out I hope to see you in
future videos make sure to you know
check out my stuff if you're into that
sort of thing and I will see you some
other time here